Thank you all for coming to this session on Therapy-Induced
Mutagenesis in Normal Tissues of Children: A Link to Late Effects.
I'm very happy with this session. I think
late effects,
particularly in children that are treated for cancer, might be the
biggest challenge for the future, as the survival of children has increased
tremendously during the last decades.
However, their treatment is, of course, quite
toxic for normal tissues. And
for a long time, we couldn't really measure or quantify this
toxicity. But due to some technical
advances in the last couple of years, we have been able to start
measuring some of these toxicities, specifically
mutagenesis caused by the therapy.
And the session today will show you three presentations on this subject.
And the first speaker will be
Yingwei Sun, Dr. Yingwei Sun from
the St. Jude's Children's Hospital,
who will present her work on studying mutagenesis underlying clonal
hematopoiesis and second cancers in children.
And last year,
Dr. Sun has been elected as a fellow of the AACR
Academy. And without further ado, I would like to invite Dr.
Sun to the stage.
Well, thank you so much, Ruben, for organizing this important
session and for giving me the opportunity to present our
work on long-term survivors of pediatric cancer.
I have--
Okay, see.
Somehow it does not work. Okay. I have nothing to
disclose.
So for those of us involved in pediatric cancer research,
cure of the cancer is not the only goal as we have to be concerned
about the adverse outcomes that happen in long-term survivors
of pediatric cancer. Therefore, in this study,
we are studying, looking at the genomic toxicity using
materials collected from adult survivors of pediatric
cancer.
So,
the technique we use for evaluating genomic toxicity
is mutational signature analysis.
Many people here already know what it is, but I just want to give a little brief
introduction so that those who are not familiar with the analytical process
can
get familiar with this. So basically, what
we do is using 96 signature features
based on the mutant site, as well as one base pair
flanking regions, to look into the profiles like this,
looking at the peaks and the spectrums to
associate these imprinting pattern with
either specific exposure or etiology.
And what I'm showing here is actually a mutational signature
we discovered from
related to thiopurine treatment that leading to
relapsed ALs a few years ago. So within
cancer patients or individuals, the genomes of the mutations actually was
contributed by a multitude of
different mutational mechanisms.
So we always use a signature extraction to deconvolute these
different contributors
that kind of shape the genome of an individual.
So our journey started by looking into clonal hematopoiesis in the
survivors,
using the blood sample.
Clonal hematopoiesis refers to acquisition of
mutations in hematopoietic stem cells, leading to
clonal expansion that can cause AML or
cardiovascular disease. In pediatric cancer survivors,
there is accelerated aging and
clonal hematopoiesis is also a very well-defined aging biomarker.
And this is a study published a few years ago, led by
Kohei Hagiwara, a
postdoc fellow then in my lab. So we used the St.
Jude LIFE cohort that comprised of about 3,000
survivors and 3,300 age-matched
controls. We performed deep targeted sequencing and
built up a statistical model to infer what is age-related versus
therapy-related clonal hematopoiesis.
Through this study, we found accelerated CH in the survivors
compared with normal controls. We also discovered therapy-related
STAT3 hotspot mutations that were highly enriched in
Hodgkin lymphoma survivors.
So to delineate what cell types were involved in
these
CH mutations, we used a platform, which
is called Tapestry, that allow us to profile
mutations along with
an antibody panel for cell type classification
at the single-cell level. And this is a work led by
Siva in our genomic laboratory. So for the study, we
profiled three Hodgkin lymphoma survivors, the blood cells,
and we discovered that mutant cells, which are shown in these red dots here,
appear to be highly enriched in the green cells,
that were
clustered based on the cell surface markers and shown to be
CD4, CD8 T cells.
So, we were looking for the enrichment mutations in these
cell types and found there's a three to tenfold enrichment compared
with the whole blood samples we analyzed.So
from the three base pair sequencing context, we noted that
these
spectrums actually resemble a mutational signature called
SBS25
by COSMIC. And this
SBS25, there is emerging evidence to show that it's associated
with procapsid exposure
that was used for treating Hodgkin lymphoma patients.
So we performed whole genome
single-cell sequencing and using the bulk
sample as a
control. And we were able to find most of
the STAT3 mutant cells were only solely
comprised with SBS25 signature, while
the wild type cells have an admix of
different signatures. And you can look at the spectrum
differences, and under this mutagenesis background, the
STAT3 mutation almost have 100% confidence to be
caused by SBS25,
linking them to procapsid exposure.
So for this published study, we only analyzed three Hodgkin
lymphoma
survivors with one mutations, and we have later expanded
this analysis to over 100
CH positive survivors, and this is a study that was led
by Siva and Nadia in my lab. She's here, and she will be
presenting her poster on Tuesday morning, and you will hear more
about the details of this analysis.
So just to highlight some interesting findings, what we found, different
mutations actually contribute to enrichment in
different cell types. And this is an example that shows the
DNMT3A mutations in 19 survivors.
Some of them were highly enriched in monocytes, and some of them were
enriched in double negative CD3+
T cells.
We were also to follow whether the mutational enrichment pattern
persisted
longitudinally using serial samples collected from the survivors.
And this is the result from one of the Hodgkin lymphoma
survivors that have the
STAT3 mutation, and we have marked the
mutant cells similarly, and also to the cell types
in orange, the color for our
CD8
T cells, and shows that the
enrichment happens at the age of
47, and the same pattern was also found
at the age of 49 and age of
51 years old. So this is a pattern
that carries through persistently throughout
life.
Oops. Don't know why I'm...
All right. I'm sorry for not hitting the right button.
So,
knowing the cell type only reveals part of a story.
What we really want to see is how the mutations impact
the cell function. So to do this, what
we figure out using whole genome transcriptome
sequencing by full-length
RNA-Seq may give us both the mutation status as
well as the expression profiles that differentiate the mutant
cells from the wild type. So we also
performed FACS sorting so that we can enrich the data with the cell
types identified in the multi-omics platform.
And this
new profile technique is called single-cell Kinex
by Pek Bao, and we have been using this for several of the
survivorship
samples.
So this is one of them that we were able to show
the clustering of these
from the full-length RNA-Seq
into different groups, and the mutant cells were indeed
clustered and were only present in two
clusters. And using the
kind of candidate markers, we were able to show that this is
highly enriched in CD8 memory T cells.
And more in-depth study presented in Nadia's poster.
So if you want to see how these mutant cells
track in the T cell differentiation lineage, go to
her poster on Tuesday.
So throughout these analysis, what we found is that
the chemotherapies the pediatric cancer patients
received 20 or 30 years ago can have an
imprint on the blood cells when they become the adult.
And in the case of the
STAT3 mutant cells, we found it leads to clonal
expansion of specific subtypes of T cells and leading
to
potential malfunction of
immune system.
So next, I want to talk about some of the real observation,
looking into the tumor materials
obtained from the survivors in adulthood.
And this is a study in collaboration, Dr.
Sam Brady from Pharmacyuk Science, and Greg Armstrong
from Epidemiology and Cancer Control, who's also the leader of
a childhood cancer survivorship study.
And I want to mention that we are very fortunate to be selected
for simultaneous publication for cancer discovery,
and this
is a QR code, and if you scan it, this paper
is hot right on the internet,
right as moment being
released.So the secondary
neoplasm cohort from CCSS, we have
include 200
FLP samples from 159 patients. Most of these, we
were able to get good quality whole genome or exome
sequences. And
we also want to note
to make sure that there is a major age differences, like
27 years, the age gap between the initial
childhood cancer and the secondary neoplasms that
identified in adulthood. So the three
secondary neoplasm that we analyzed, including breast,
meningioma, and thyroid cancer from survivors of
leukemia, Hodgkin's lymphoma, and central neural system.
And these
survivors being exposed to a variety of DNA-damaging agents.
Most prominent one is radiation.
So first, we looked at the differences of mutation burdens
in the SNs versus de novo cancers.
So we can see that in meningioma and thyroid
cancer, there's elevated mutation burdens compared with a de
novo cancer. In breast cancer, at the first
glance, you may consider that the de novo cancer have
higher mutation burden than
SNs. This is because the age of onset of our SN
is much younger than the de novo cancer.
So when you adjust for age
and tumor purity, stage, and histology, the
difference is not significant. So similar increase
in indel mutation burden was also observed in meningioma
and thyroid cancer.
Now we go deep into the mutational signature analysis,
and we were able to find eight
COSMIC mutation signatures from this cohort.
No new signature was identified. So of the signature
we found included
cisplatin signatures in meningioma and thyroid cancer,
indicating the tumor genomes of the adult cancer actually being
affected by prior exposures in pediatric cancer treatment.
So another thing that we noticed that
SBS5, which is commonly recognized as a
age-related signature, appear to have the highest
abundance in our SNs. So we raised a kind of
a bold hypothesis, can this be related to
chemotherapy exposure?
So first, we looked into the association between the
SBS5 burden versus the exposure, and we
found nitrogen mustard accolades appear to be
associated with elevated burden in breast cancer
as well as
meningioma. So we didn't find this association in thyroid cancer.
This is because the expression of
LDH1A1 in thyroid actually can lead to
cyclophosphamide inactivation.
So next, we want to show, can we prove this
experimentally? So we performed an in vitro drug treatment
using MCF10A cell line, which is a breast
cell line, and treated with
cyclophosphamide and cisplatin as a positive
control. We also included untreated cells
as well as the one treated with cytarabine, and it is not
a mutagenic agent, and a combination of
cyclophosphamide with cytarabine.
So the experiments were performed with three triplicate,
and we then isolated the single cells for whole genome
sequencing.
So what we found is that indeed, there is increased mutation burdens
of cyclophosphamide-treated cells compared with the controls and
cytarabine. And also, the combinatorial
treatment of cytarabine and
cyclophosphamide also lead to a slightly
reduced mutation burden compared with the treatment by a single agent.
So now going deep to the signatures, so we took the raw signature
from the cyclophosphamide treatment, subtracted out the
controls. They lead to a very consistent
flat signatures across all the three triplet.
And when we look at the deconvolute signatures with
COSMIC, we found they resemble mostly to the three flat
signatures, SBS3, 5, 48, that were
in COSMIC.
So does this signature contribute to the SBS5
that we detected in our patient sample?
So to evaluate that, we performed a simulation
analysis. What we did is taking about 600 SNVs,
which is a median increase of
treated SNs versus untreated that we found,
following this profile and
synthesize these mutations and mix it
with
treatment-naive secondary
SNs, and then perform the mutational signature
extraction on the original ones as well as the
simulated profile. And we were able to show
that indeed, SBS5 was the most prominent signatures
found by this simulation analysis, while the cosine
similarity of COSMIC signature is pretty comparable in the
original and
simulated data, suggesting the robustness of this result.
And the same result was also found by
meningioma.So the last thing we
checked is looking at the genomic landscape of SNs versus de novo
cancers. First, let's take a look at the thyroid cancer.
So what we first discovered is that there is an increased
kinase fusion in
thyroid SNs, and this is almost replicating
Dr. Steve Chanock's
study,
Chernobyl-exposed thyroid cancer,
indicating the importance of radiation in
inducing thyroid cancer.
In meningioma, we found that
NF2 disruption by structural variation, which is shown
here, appeared to be a common event in
meningioma SNs. This has also been found in a
radiation-induced meningioma study, but absent in a de
novo meningioma.
And then interestingly, in the same
meningioma cohort, we also find two cases that has been
found with
platinum-induced signatures, also have NF2 splice site
mutations. When we lay out the splice site mutations on top
of the signature spectrum, we see that they are on the peak
of the cisplatinum signature, showing that they have a high
probability of being induced by cisplatinum exposure.
So the breast cancer
SNs actually almost look identical to the de novo
breast cancer studies profiled by the Cancer Genome
Atlas project.
So putting all this data together allows us to start to
evaluate all the different exposures contributing to
defects in normal tissues, leading to secondary
neoplasm. So let's first take radiation, which
induces double-stranded breaks and leads to the formation of
indels as well as rearrangements.
And in the secondary neoplasm, we
observed the enriched indel burdens as well as
IDF5 signatures.
In the case of
thyroid cancer, we see the enrichment for kinase fusions
and in meningioma, the NF2
disruption.
So for nitrogen mustards and other accolades, they
increase the mutation burdens in normal cells and leading
to the flat SBS5-like signatures,
in both breast cancer and meningioma.
For platinum treatment,
again introduces the mutation burdens, also
resulting in the SBS 31 and 35 signatures
at the diagnostic samples of meningioma and the thyroid
cancer. And we believe that the NF2 splice site mutations
observed in meningioma appear to be related to this
prior exposure of platinum accolades.
So from this work, we found that cytotoxicity
of childhood cancer treatment
may cause secondary neoplasm development in adult survivors.
This further emphasizes the importance of surveillance
for the prevention of secondary neoplasm.
So how to carry out molecular-based surveillance more effectively,
we are exploring two approaches. The first is based on
the DNA sequencing data. So we are looking into
single-cell whole genome sequencing followed by SNV and indel
mutational signature analysis in blood
samples of survivors to see if this could be an indicator
for secondary neoplasm in
the future. And for me personally, I like to analyze
structural variations,
because they are related to radiation and topoisomerase
inhibitor-related
structural changes. So we are also looking into the possibility of
doing that. So one of the new tools we recently published,
originally designed for finding rapid gene fusion events in
clinical, turned out to be adaptable for this
evaluation. And we are also interested in looking
into utilizing the single-cell full-length RNA-seq
to see if we can subtract the noises from the signals for
mutational signature analysis.
So finally, I'd like to thank all my collaborators in St.
Jude and other institutions, in particular,
the Childhood Cancer Survivorship Studies and St.
Jude LIFE for the survivors and the family who enrolled in these studies
that allow us to
look at the long-term effect of
therapy leading to iterative improvement, and my funding
agency and National Cancer Institute. Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Zhang, for a wonderful talk. Are there questions? There.
Yes. This is Steven Chanock from the NCI. Thank you, Jingmi.
That was a terrific talk. I have a
question that you may or may not be able to answer.
When you looked at your mutational signatures for breast and meningioma where you
have SBSs,
in St. Jude LIFE, you know exactly how much chemotherapy they got and when they got
it. Do you see any relationship between the amount
or the timing of that chemotherapy and the
degree to which you see the SBS? So are you able
to map in any way that-
Yeah, this is a-
Because I know that's a theme that's going to come up in more talks today.
Yeah, this is a fantastic question.
So I kind of
laid out there, talking about the problems we see, that
difficult to separate the dosage of treatment
versus effect because most of the treatment was based on
combinatorial therapy rather than single agents.
So this is where in our in vitro study, we had this design of
combinatorial treatment of cytarabine and
cyclophosphamide, and the
combination seems to diminish the effect.
So,
unfortunately, we did not see a positive
associationYou know, using the data we have, because we
cannot separate these complex
interactions.
Hi, Nuria.
Hi. Nuria Lopez-Bigas from Barcelona. Very nice talk. Thank you.
I have two questions. One is about the platinum signature.
I saw in your plot that you only see it in, I think it was three
secondary neoplasms.
Mm-hmm.
Is this because these were the only three that were treated with platinum, or you
could see some cases that are treatment, but you
don't see the signature in the...
Yeah, there are cases that we do see they were
exposed to treatment, but we did not see the signature of
cisplatinum. So this could be related to the sensitivity,
how we analyze the data and things.
We had to deal with very challenging problem of analyzing FFPE
samples
and
a lot of effort, almost take two or three years to
generate data that could be used for good quality.
And this is where I think in the future studies, we can use fresh
frozen tissues. This may enable us to get
more informative results.
One another question about signature five and the other treatments.
What are your thoughts about, is this the same mechanism than signature five
correlating with age, or it just happened to-
Yeah, I think-
... by coincidence to have a similar pattern?
Yeah, this is an excellent question.
I don't think it's related to age, and this is because of
the pattern is flat. So this is why in the original
patients sample analysis, because of signature extraction methods
seems to have some preference of assigning signatures to the
native, the endogenous signatures already present.
That's why we see SBS5. So we call this flat,
not SBS5.
Thanks, Xingui. Lindsay Morton from NCI. It's terrific to see these data.
I'm wondering if you can comment a little bit on the clonality of the signatures
that you identified and-
Yeah
... were you able to look at clonal versus subclonal patterns?
This is excellent question. Again,
because of FFPE and the artifacts related to this,
we actually were asked by our reviewer to only looking for
clonal events. So, that was the result we get.
And again, I want to emphasize if there is fresh frozen tissues in the
future, that will give more informative result and hopefully can
answer the question you raised.
So,
Seisho Wang from Kyoto University. And so excellent talk and thank you very much.
So I'm very much interested in the structure variations.
So many secondary cancer, so have
the copy number alteration or structure variation as a copy number
alteration. So you can estimate the timing of the
copy number alterations, because of the comparing the variant
frequency on the XAT chromosome.
Mm-hmm.
So do you see any evidence suggesting that the timing of copy
number
gain is at the same time of the chemotherapy?
Yeah. I think this will serve as
the iteration or next
project. So again-
Mm
... for this FFPE sample, we have very limited power for detecting
structural variation using the material.
We actually were not able to do a systematic analysis,
so this is why we want to, kind of in the current phase, we want
to look deep in the blood cells and also in some of the cancer
models like PDXs we have exposed versus unexposed to
gain some insight and to-
Mm
... kind of make sure that we have the right tool for studying these.
With whole genome sequencing, you have enough number of mutations in the
cancer samples, and using the XAT data, you
can estimate the timing of the acquisition of this copy number
gains and
roughly, of course.
Yeah. Thank you. We just had to deal with the
challenges with FFPE for this particular study.
I'm sorry. Very much, I'm sorry. But you have the newly diagnosed patients, so
many.
So because you're St. Jude, so, so many samples.
Those samples are from CCSS, not from St. Jude.
Thank you.
Final question here. Sam.
Thank you. That was a really wonderful talk.
Children with Hodgkin's disease have got this peculiarity that after treatment,
they are at lifelong risk of getting
graft versus host disease from just a blood transfusion, so they need lifelong
irradiated blood. And it's incredibly difficult to explain because they don't get
myeloablative treatment. I just wonder whether the STAT3 mutations that
you found might just explain that, and have you done functional work
on the STAT3 mutant clones?
Yeah. So this is a study that we are collaborating with our immunology
colleagues who are creating mouse models-
Okay
... to be able to evaluate this.
Yeah. So we kind of did some of the single
cell trajectory analysis, at least can
see where they happen in the lineage.
So
we only can do so much with
all mixed data analysis, and cannot answer the question without
experimentation.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Zhang.
So our second speaker is Dr. Sam Benatti of the Wellcome
Sanger Institute, who recently was announced as the new head of the Department
of Pediatrics at the University of Cambridge and director of the Cambridge Children
Research Institute.
And Sam or Dr. Benatti will present his work on
liver-specific platinum mutagenesis in children using duplex sequencing.
So Sam.
Thank you, Ruben, for
inviting me. It's a real joy to be here.
So
I'm going to talk a little bit more about the field to give a bit
more perhaps of an introduction. I'll talk about the experiment and our
data and then conclude on a couple of things.
So
I try very hard not to study mutational signatures, but
it's quite difficult not to when one is interested in genomics.
And we got interested in the field of
mutagenesis in normal tissues some years ago, sort of around 2019,
'20, with a local patient in Cambridge who developed
AML after having been treated for neuroblastoma.
And one of the beauties of the National Health Service is that it's very good at
banking stuff, and it's quite relatively easy to get hold of stuff.
And what we tried to do in this trial is then to reconstruct how she's gone from
the beginning of the treatment all the way to leukemia.
And I won't talk to you about all the detail here.
The key thing is this,
one thing that we did find is that halfway through induction treatments, at that
point, this child will have had about half of their platinum treatment.
She had developed two hematopoietic clones.
And it's quite important to
just appreciate at the moment that percentage number there, 1.5%,
7.8%. Those are huge clones in the
clonal hematopoiesis world. And one critical thing here, so this is
normal blood, and the most critical thing to point out here is that there isn't
a driver mutation in there. And because most studies of clonal
hematopoiesis, for cost reasons, will confine themselves to
a few leukemogenic genes, this clonal
hematopoiesis would not have been detected had one done a normal
clonal hematopoiesis study. The only way to find this at that time was to
just sequence the hell out of the samples, which is what we did.
The second thing to say is, and very similar to what you've just heard before, is
that the key driver event in this leukemia, which is a
PDDRN11 mutation, was caused with a near 100%
probability by mutational signatures due to platinum treatment.
In this study, it's a very small paper.
We had one more child, and I'll just mention her because that was quite
fascinating. She had an MLL rearranged leukemia after
neuroblastoma, and MLL rearranged leukemias after cancer treatment
historically have been ascribed to etoposide.
Now, what was quite fascinating in her is that before she had the
MLL rearrangement in her normal blood, she also developed
platinum clonal hematopoiesis and acquired the
MLL mutation on top of the platinum clone.
Now, I could go on about this for ages.
I think that's a fundamental question about that idea about
etoposide and MLL, but I won't take you on that tangent, so
I'll try to stay on track. And then we had one more child.
This is just a handful of children in whom we found clonal hematopoiesis, again,
driverless. She unfortunately died, so we don't know whether she would have
developed AML or not.
So what we learned from that experiment is that platinum-mediated
mutagenesis is also pervasive in children. And of course, it would be.
There's absolutely no reason why it should not be,
but the literature is a little bit confusing, and clones were driverless.
Now, there are two major studies on survivors.
One is this wonderful, wonderful paper from St.
Jude's that we heard about, and another is from MSKCC from Eli
Papayiannis. And in both studies, there wasn't really much
evidence that platinum clonal hematopoiesis exists in
survivors. But this is a technical problem.
So the way these experiments are designed is that if they discover
something, it is definitely there, but if it isn't there, it doesn't
mean that it is there. And I'll try to explain that in a bit more detail.
So what is the technical issue?
Starting with the fertilized egg, so I'm just showing you a fertilized egg here,
and in black are the germline mutations.
As the fertilized egg divides, it acquires mutations,
probably about one substitution per cell division.
So every cell, every normal cell in our body is
riddled with substitutions.
If we were to sequence this normal
tissue now, so imagine this is now a normal tissue composed of millions and
millions of cells, what we would see is there are germline mutations, and the blue
numbers are the cell-specific mutations.
Now, because of how whole genome sequencing or
conventional sequencing works is it doesn't see the mutations in
front of it right now. It sees the mutations of the
cell that the tissue is derived from.
So if I were to do whole genome sequencing on this particular tissue,
all I would see are the black mutations, the germline mutations.
So
cell-specific mutations are entirely invisible to
conventional sequencing, and that then explains-- Oh, hello, Lisa, wonderful to
see you.
Oh, and Mike. Gosh, what a pleasure.
That then explains why we cannot see these mutations.
So what happens when we have got mutagen exposure, such as platinum
chemotherapy? We get damage, and I'm showing you the damage here with these
red letters, and each damage is unique to each
individual cell. So again, if we were to sequence
this piece of normal tissue with the red mutations, we wouldn't see the
red mutations because they're unique to each individual
cell. The only way that we can see them in mother nature
is if there was a clonal expansion, and that's what I'm trying to show here, and
then that cell becomes the dominant clone, and then we could see the
genome of the cell from which this derived from.
So if we get a relapse after platinum exposure, we
will always see platinum mutations.
So what can we do to see them? So we either
need a clonal expansion or we have to make a clonal expansion, which is
incredibly difficult. And in the previous talk, you
just saw this sort of mentioned in a corner.
It's incredibly laborious to take individual cells and to clone
them, and it's not an experiment that is particularly scalable.
And Ruben will probably show you some data.
He's done some phenomenal work in that field.
And then the other option is to do single-cell DNA sequencing, which a few
years wasn't really possible at base pair resolution that was sort of
high enough quality to call mutations. But now it probably is.
And are you going to show us some data?
Wonderful.And then there is another way around to
get to the tissues in the normal mutations. That's called duplex sequencing.
It's a technology that's been around for many, many years.
There are different implementations.
The implementation at Sanger is called nanosequencing, which was developed by Inigo
Martincorena. It's an incredibly powerful method that builds on the
following principle. So what I'm showing you here is a molecule of
DNA, and on this end here, you see an artifact, and
so this artifact is a mutant base. But what is different
between this artifact and this real mutation here is that this one
is present in one strand, whereas this one here is present in both strands.
So the principle of duplex sequencing, therefore, is to tag
each individual strand of DNA, and then what we can do is we can
call mutations on each strand individually and ask the question: Do we see it on
both or just on one? And what that does is
it ramps up the specificity of mutation calling to an
incredible, incredible fidelity, such that we can
now call mutations in individual molecules of DNA, and
thus we can interrogate normal tissues.
The advantage of nanosequencing are the difference.
It's not necessarily an advantage.
It's a different kind of experiment, but what it allows us to do is to
interrogate just normal tissues.
We don't have to clone individual cells, and we haven't got the expense
of whole-genome DNA sequencing. We can interrogate
millions and millions of cells in one experiment.
So the experiment that I'm going to do, I just need to acknowledge two people.
One is Anna Wenger, who was a postdoc in my lab.
She's now a group leader in her home country in Sweden at the University of
Gothenburg, and the other is Fuad Rouhani.
Fuad is a transplant surgeon at King's College London.
King's College is one of those motherships, the birthplace of modern hepatology,
and he's also a group lead at the Francis Crick Institute.
And really, without him, we wouldn't have been able to do this experiment.
So what we decided to do is, let's look at
a
solid normal organ rather than blood, and then what organ would we
look at? So if we think about our practice, there aren't many tumor
types where we would get an entire organ.
We'd get kidneys, we'd get livers, and that's about it.
One might get a little bit of normal tissue around other tumor types, for most
really, the only two tumor types that I can think of are liver
and kidney. Now, the problem, or not the
problem, the issue with kidney tumors is that, of course, we don't pretreat them
with platinum agents. When we do give chemotherapy, it's usually
non-platinum-based chemotherapy.
So liver tumors, hepatoblastoma, the most common type of
children's liver cancer, was an ideal case for what we wanted to do
is because these children get pretreated with platinum agents, either
one or two, and then some children have got whole liver resection.
It's those children that we targeted.
We work very closely with the pathologists, who very kindly then slice the
liver for us, and I apologize for this rather unpalatable picture.
And what we did is we took multiple
normal liver biopsies of these livers.
And this is to give you sort of an overview of the
scale of the experiment. In total, we looked at 155 liver
biopsies plus some other tissues, and these liver biopsies
importantly included treated liver biopsies, untreated with
cisplatin, cisplatin and carboplatin, with or without SDS.
And the reason why I mention SDS is as follows.
SDS is a chelating agent which we use in hepatoblastoma treatment to prevent
ototoxicity, and we had just a little bit of a concern that maybe
that's going to interfere with what we will see, and therefore, we tried very hard
to target children who had cisplatin without SDS.
We also have got non-hepatoblastoma liver tissue and other tissues.
So it's quite a vast experiment. And we divided it into two parts, a
discovery study for the sample here, and then a validation study where we
re-interrogated the previous samples and added more.
So the data in the discovery cohort.
The first finding is this. So what I'm showing you here is interrogating the
normal tissues, blood, normal liver, and liver tumors
by conventional whole genome sequencing.
And as I explained to you before, we would expect to see a lot of
mutations in liver tumors because the readout is the
most common ancestor of the tumor, whereas in the normal tissue,
we see barely any mutations. We see germline mutations, but we barely see
any somatic mutations, and the mutations that we see are sort
of mutations of the first or second cell divisions, so
postzygotic mutations with a very high VAF.
This is a log scale here, and we've also plotted what one would expect to see in
normal adult blood and in normal adult livers.
And this is now what whole-genome nanosequencing shows, and it's quite dramatic.
So we can see that the mutation burden of children exposed to
platinum in black is elevated to that what we
would see in adults, and the same is true for the liver.
And of course, the mutation burden of the tumors barely changes because
we already have got a clonal readout, and it just adds a few extra
mutations that we wouldn't have seen.
And also note, this experiment gives us a sense of what is the
normal mutation burden in children's blood and in children's
normal liver, and it sits here about wherever it is, one to
200. So I hope I can show you just how dramatic this technology
is in revealing that hidden universe of normal tissue mutations.
Then the next thing, and this is a thing that we sort of didn't expect to find, and
it took us quite a long time to accept that this really is
true, is that in liver, there was a
novel and liver-specific mutational signature of platinum
exposure. So you've seen these plots in the previous talks.
I won't go through them in great detail.
On the x-axis, we've got all the different mutations in their
trinucleotide context, so the base before and after.
On the y-axis is the mutation burden.
You can ignore this, you can ignore that, and these down here, these are known
platinum signatures that we just plotted so you get a sense of what do
normal platinum signatures look like.
And what we see in the liver is this very different pattern.We've used
two different ways to extract this, and then the other thing that these
algorithms do is they sort of put a number to how confident the
algorithm is in the result, and this is called confidence with
this and stability in that, and in both cases, the confidence is
incredibly high. So this is as true as it gets in the space
of mutational signatures.
Now let's validate and extend that.
So the first thing that we did is we looked at all published data, and a huge
thank you to a bunch of people who provided their data, and particularly Adam
Schlain from SickKids. And we said, "Well, let's look for the
signature in existing data." And what you can see is we've got normal liver, we've
got cohorts of children, and pediatric liver tumors from a French
study.
In this cohort, I should say, were three children who had
hepatoblastomas that
are relapses, and I'll explain in a moment
why that is important. So first of all, this is sort of the control
analysis. What we've done now is we've again used two different methods to ask
the question, is the signature present?
And one can draw arbitrary cutoffs of if it's above 10% with
both methods, then we believe it.
And what you see here in this terrible brown
color, these crosses are the samples from our study, so
they are our positive control. And in blue highlighted are all
the tumors from this external data sources that had been platinum
exposed. And what you can see here is that what we find in these are
SPF 3135 and SPF carboplatin, the carboplatin signature
described by Nuria, who is also sitting here in the audience.
And as we would expect, we do find platinum signatures
in the recurrences of tumors that had been exposed
to platinum.
Now let's look for the new signature, and this is an extraordinary result.
There were six tumors in this study that were recurrences of
hepatoblastoma that had been
exposed to cisplatin, and the new signature highlights
those six tumors. The one here down there, six wasn't terribly
convincing, but when we looked further into the data, six was mostly riddled with
artifacts which were drowning the signature.
So this is incredibly convincing in picking out those
six cases with a new signature, validating that this idea of
the liver specific platinum signature really is a thing.
The next thing that we did is a cell line experiment.
So let's focus on the bottom bit
first. So these four rows, and this is external data.
So this is previously published data by Rosen's group.
And what they had done is they had done that difficult experiment of exposing a
cell culture to platinum agents, then taking a single cell and growing
it up to learn what the mutational signatures are in those cells.
And we analyzed their data and asked the question, do we find
our
novel mutational signature in their data?
It's quite extraordinary again, and here what we use is a method that gives
a P value of the probability of it actually being
there. So we see the signature in
liver tumor cells that had been exposed to cisplatin, but
not in a breast line. And again, in the independent experiment, we saw the same
again. And just to highlight, this is not data that we generated.
This is someone else's experiment.
And then we repeated the experiment, this time using a monocyte line as a
control and whole genome NanoSeq, and again, we can validate this notion.
Interestingly, the carboplatin only exposed liver line didn't
harbor that signature.
And then
the next thing that we wanted to assess, so we cause a lot of mutations, and
they're different in liver compared to blood.
Could they have functional potential?
And this is where NanoSeq can be focused on
genes rather than the whole genome.
And then that enables us to do two things.
First of all, identify individual mutations, but then also
make a statement by calculating damaging
mutations over silent mutations, could a particular
gene be under selection by these mutations?
And this is this large validation study here.
We interrogated 238 genes, mainly cancer genes, and
a few genes that have been linked to metabolic liver disease in adults.
I'll sort of
whiz a little bit through the experiment because we are getting towards the end of
the time. I'll probably skip this and I'll probably skip that.
I want to show you this here. So this one is...
What we try to show you here are the different tissues on the Y-axis, and
then again, using two different methods to assess the probability of the
mutational signature being there, and black is what you need to look for.
And what you can see is that it's present in normal liver and in exposed
liver tumors, unexposed normal liver, but it's absent from unexposed
liver. There was one sample that was doing funny things because there wasn't
actually a liver in here. The problem was that the mutation burden was very
low, so we were a little worried about this being erroneous.
So we subjected this particular sample set to whole genome analysis, and what
we found is the confusion was coming from this yellow here.
It's a slightly geeky notion from the carboplatin signature.
And then finally, could the mutations be functional?
So we now took each individual coding mutation and annotated them
as if there were mutations that we found in a cancer and called potential
driver mutations. And a driver mutation in this context, we took a
very conservative approach to the annotation.
So we really only called a driver something that anyone would call a driver.
So an NRAS G12 mutation or beta-catenin
S45, that kind of variant.
And here is a result. I think this is quite an interesting headline.
So in the normal liver, we interrogated about 110,000 molecules
of DNA. We found about 22,000 non-synonymous
variants, and 1,500 of thoseOne
would consider to be cancer-causing mutations.
And that's quite
staggering. And just remember, we have only sampled the
tiniest of proportion of molecules of DNA
in that whole liver. If we look at the gene, the
mutability is entirely driven by size.
So it's not selection, which we felt was unsurprising given the short
interval between exposure and sampling.
And the second thing to say is, what we're trying to highlight here in yellow is,
that most of these variants with pathogenic
potential were caused by the novel
signature. So
there are two sets of conclusions here.
There is,
I think, a sort of general that's relevant for us, and then a sort of more
fundamental cancer genomics set of conclusions.
So for us, I think the take home message is that platinum-agent
mutagenesis in children is just as pervasive as
it is in adults. There's nothing special about children.
They are there, it's just we have used
not quite the right technology to look at the question
before. The second thing is what I hope
I've been able to show you, is that very dramatic elevation of the mutation
burden of that of children to that of old adults.
And another question that I just want to throw in here, when we study late
effects, we of course access blood because blood is easily accessible.
But we need to just question that notion whether it really is a faithful report of
what may happen elsewhere in the body.
And on a more sort of fundamental level, what was really quite fascinating here
from a more geeky genomics point of view is this concept of a
tissue-specific signature, the generation of variants with
functional potential, and then for me this really is a link to late effects.
Now that's
not that long a stretch for cancer because of course cancer
is caused by mutations. It might be a bit of a stretch for non-cancer
disease, although we are beginning to learn that non-cancer
diseases may also be driven by somatic mutation.
I think for us it provides a really fascinating and
important opportunity to try to link specific
late effects, perhaps to exposure and
mutagenesis.
And with that, I would like to thank my wonderful team, and here is
Anna, the postdoc who did all the work, my funders, and finally
the children and the families who are so generous in
contributing their tissues to our research. Thank you.
Thank you, Sam.
Hi. So, Seicho Goh from Kyoto University.
Very nice talk, and I really enjoy your talk.
So my question is that you analyze the bulk
tissues or
sorted for the hepatocyte.
This is because NanoSeq can detect any cells
regardless of the cell type. So this is very important
with the constituent of the bulk cells.
So because cell liver have the hepatocyte, bile cells,
Kupffer cells, and endothelial cells, many type of cells, you
estimate how much frequency those cells are found
in your bulk sample, the sorted cells?
Yeah. Thank you. That's an excellent question. So the point is this.
The challenge with NanoSeq is that when you subject it or any kind
of duplexing, when you take a piece of normal tissue, it'll interrogate the
mutations in the entirety of the tissue in all the different cell types.
So one can't say that these mutations definitively come from cell type X or
Y. So we thought about this long and hard, but then took a view that because in a
piece of liver, most cells are hepatocytes or of the
liver lineage, it's an okay sort of shortcut to not
sorting. The cell line experiment where we have a pure cell line,
then sort of validates or demonstrates the fact that
that particular mutation signature arises from hepatocyte or
hepatocyte lineages. But thank you for that.
So most cells are hepatocyte, really?
Correct. Yeah.
So probably some many types.
There are many different cell types, but if you just sort of broadly subdivide it
into liver, liver-derived bile, and that kind of universe,
and then a few blood cells, that's the level at which we sort of
felt it's okay to say most of this is liver and liver derived.
Uh-huh. But still it would be very interesting to separate each cell.
It would be fascinating. Absolutely, yeah.
Because some small fraction, but very high mutation rate.
Yeah.
So
we don't know.
I couldn't agree more. Thank you.
Meredith.
Yeah. Thanks, Sam. That was such a great talk.
I wondered a little bit about the liver and its regeneration
capacity being such a different organ than
the kidney, which was your other option, even though they don't get platinum.
I wondered if you think that has anything to do with the susceptibility, plus the
young age, of course, of the children.
Thank you, Meredith. I don't think that the liver is particularly prone to
mutagenesis. I think that's just what platinum does, and that's why platinum is so
bloody effective, because it damages DNA and pushes cells over the
edge.
For the regeneration, that's a really fascinating thing.
So Farad, who is a liver surgeon, sort of currently concocting this
experiment where sometimes they get the opportunity to
resample a liver that has regrown to then first of all
ask the question, what happens to the mutations?
But then also, if that liver that has regrown, has it regrown from a single
cell or is it sort of a polyclonal thing?
But it's an utterly fascinating field. Thank you.
Thanks.
Sam, absolutely terrific as always.
So
my question is a little bit different.
In the cell-- Briefly, you showed the cell culture were suggesting that there was
sort of an early-- It was happening relatively early, which led me to
think, can you actually time when things get going?
Like A,
when does that signature switch? Is it
long, is it short? And is it correlated at all with dose or other
aspects of the drug? High dose, low dose, intermediate, and that kind of thing.
So within the limitations of
doing the dose calculations, we do think that it is related to dose.
We also think that carboplatin and cisplatin
exaggerate each other, augment each other.
In terms of when it arises, so we had one very unfortunate child in there who
died after a single dose, and we got hold of the tissue within
three weeks, and even there, we saw the signature in the liver, which makes us
think it is sort of, I don't know how instantaneous it is, but a
single dose is enough. And one won't be able to do detailed
time course, but if one were able to do a detailed time course, it would be an
utterly fascinating thing to address.
And you have the sense that once it's there, it's there permanently.
Yes.
I can't see how it would ever disappear unless there were a
population of cells that would then have a clonal advantage by not having the
mutation and then regenerate the liver.
But of course, because it's universally pervasive, I can't really
see how one could get rid of those signatures.
So I think they will stay with children for life.
We've got a follow-up experiment doing just a bunch of nano seqs on
much, much older children, adults who've had platinum as children, just to prove
that point. But going back again to
previous research, I think the notion that
platinum mutagenesis isn't a thing in the blood of childhood cancer
survivors is an entirely technical limitation of the past.
Thanks.
Thank you.
There's another question here. Yeah.
Thanks. That was a terrific talk. I've been sitting here thinking a little bit
about this new technology and how you're getting a
better sense of kind of baseline mutation rates, and thinking from an
epidemiologist point of view about how-- thinking about
additive versus multiplicative.
So I'm wondering if you could comment on some of the heterogeneity in mutation
rates by age, other factors, maybe sex,
by tissue type, and then how you think some of these exposures, like platinum,
might kind of interact or amplify.
I'm using a variety of synonyms that are very non-technical, right?
But to ask of like, is there some sort of a synergistic effect or does platinum
just add on, or does it matter what that baseline mutation rate
is?
If I may, I'm going to not give you the answer to your question and give you a
different answer that I would like to give.
So the reason why I'm not giving you the answer to your question, because it's an
entirely valid question, it's quite complex and sort of outside my field, and
I don't think we've got a grasp of that data.
But you're making a really important point that if you were to scale this out
to an epidemiological scale and over a lifetime
of a child, we could learn incredible things.
The one thing that I will say is that we started looking a
little bit in children with predispositions, and there is the odd, really
quite fascinating signal, even in predispositions that have got nothing to do with
DNA repair, and that I find quite fascinating.
I think there's another line of inquiry that we could take and
try to learn about what is actually happening there.
And it's part of the reason why you're at higher risk of
having multiple tumors in a predisposition, perhaps a little bit more
than the predisposition, going back to the notion of let's think very carefully
about how much chemotherapy we give. But anyway. Thank you.
All right. Let's thank Sam again for his presentation.
All right, so
the next is me. I forgot to introduce myself during the
introduction of this session. My name is Ruben van Boxtel.
I'm a group leader at the Princess Maxima Center in Utrecht, the
Netherlands.
And I want to show some of our new data where we try to combine
single cell genome and transcriptome sequencing in the hematopoietic system of
children that have been treated
for cancer.
So these are my disclosures.
And as I said also during the introduction of the session, the
survival of children with cancer has increased tremendously during the last
decades. And the survival is now more than 80%,
which is really wonderful, but this comes with a cost because these children, they
are confronted with
chronic health problems later in life, including the development
of second cancers, which we have heard about in the previous talks.
And we know that for a long time already that the
chemotherapy, the cancer treatment that we're using can be
mutagenic, we know this because of sequencing cancer cells that
survive this treatment in metastasis or relapses.
But for a long time, the mutagenic potential
of the treatment in normal cells was not known.
And there's different way to study this.
So we heard the duplex sequencing,
as well as bulk sequencing of
clonal expansions which naturally occur in tissues.
But we wanted to set out for single cell whole genome
sequencing. And as was already explained by Sam, what we
previously did to do this is to clonally expand individual
stem cells. The reason why we do this is because this is the only way to get
enough DNA to actually do sequencing, because one cell doesn't
have enough DNA for a sequencing.
And so for multiple tissues, we applied this,
extracted the stem cells, performed clonal expansion, and sequenced
them.
But in the last few years, we've also started working more on
doing whole genome amplification of single cells and do direct single cell
sequencing using biochemical whole genome amplification.
And actually, this has become better and better, and we are using this method
called primary template-directed amplification, which actually reduces a
lot of the artifacts which are naturally
associated with these whole genome amplification
procedures.However, this procedure still
introduces a lot of artifacts. And so what we have done in the last few
years is develop a machine learning algorithm that can actually flag
these artifacts. And actually it can do that really
accurately, and then we can remove those artifacts.
And
so actually now if we compare this clone seq, so the
sequencing of
single cells that have been clonally expanded versus these PTA amplified
cells, we can actually see that we have similar mutation loads.
And this is hematopoietic stem cells of young children.
And actually the lower the mutation burden is,
the more you will see the artifacts popping up.
So actually showing that this direct single cell whole genome
sequencing can be quite accurate.
And so we applied this method to several tissues, including the
hematopoietic system, which I showed you here.
This is mutation accumulation in
a normal hematopoietic system during life.
Of course, also what we see, and actually you see this in all tissues, is that
there is a linear accumulation of mutations actually quite accurately.
So we can accurately estimate the age of somebody by simply looking at how many
mutations their cells have. And this is caused by clock-like signatures
which are
active during life.
So specifically this SBS1 and SBS5, 5 we already heard.
And then the hematopoietic system has also a unique signature, which is called SBS
blot. And all of these signatures are linearly active, so
constantly active during life. And the question now is really what
is happening if these cells are treated with
chemotherapy? And it's very important that, that's the message of this slide, is
that you always should correct for the age, always age normalize this
if you're comparing different individuals.
And so to answer the question whether chemotherapeutics is mutagenic
for normal tissues,
some time ago we've collected this cohort of childhood cancer
survivors that developed a therapy-related leukemia later in life.
So they were treated for a first cancer, which are indicated here, so a variety
of primary cancers.
And then after a while developed a second leukemia,
so a leukemia which is unrelated to the initial cancer.
And the reason why we're interested in this cohort is because we could get
hematopoietic
cells from diagnose one, which is either bone marrow or blood
as well as follow up, so after the child was successfully treated
for the cancer,
and also diagnosed two when the child was diagnosed with the
therapy-related AML. And so we could follow in time what the
chemotherapy does with the hematopoietic system.
And so what we see is that after time you can see that
these children, so at diagnosis one, there is no difference in mutation load
in a normal hematopoietic stem cells, which is already quite interesting
because many of these children suffer from ALL and in
many cases, the blast percentage is higher than 90%.
So it's only very few cells that make the whole hematopoietic system.
But this is at least for the stem cells, not associated with increased mutagenesis.
But then at the follow-up and the diagnose two mutation load goes up.
And this is true for the
single base substitution as well as the indels.
In these cells we couldn't find any structural variation.
And what is causing this increase?
And so for this we also performed the
mutational signature analysis
which is summarized in this graph here. I will walk you through it.
Each bar here is a single cell that we sequence from different
patients and in different gray scales
you see the mutations which are attributed to clock-like
signatures. And in color these are the mutations which are
attributed to specific chemotherapeutics or unknown signatures.
And what we saw is actually that not many of the chemotherapeutics that
these children have received actually cause the
mutagenesis in these children.
One thing that does cause it is the platinum drugs which we already heard about.
Thiopurines is another one where which also we saw clear
patterns. We also heard about this.
I think the difference between the platinum and the thiopurines is that if these
children that were treated with platinum, we see the signature in all cells,
whereas in thiopurines we only see them in a subset of cells.
We also find some novel signatures in these patients in which we saw the
novel signatures. They all underwent hematopoietic stem cell transplantation and
in an older study we actually showed that some of the antiviral
drug that these children get can be highly mutagenic, specifically ganciclovir.
But most patients actually just showed normal clock-like processes.
But if we looked a bit deeper into these patients, we did see that
the number of mutations in these cells is increased up to three times
higher. So it seems that they have accelerated clock-like
mutagenesis.
In another study which we published last year,
we showed that also if children are exposed or
fetal cells are exposed during pregnancies, we can actually also in the fetal
cell
see increased mutagenesis because of the treatment.
And this was a cohort of women that were treated for cancer
during pregnancy,
and we
could assess the cord blood when the children were born.
And also here we saw that the mutation load can go up to five times
higher than what you would expect at birth.
Oh yeah, and what we saw is this data mostly showed that
again platinum was associated with mutagenesis, but we also saw that
cyclophosphamide was also associated with mutagenesis.
And we also set out to validate this
by taking umbilical cord blood hematopoietic stem cells,
so primary human stem cells and treating them in vitro with these
different compounds and indeed show that...
that platinum and the mafosfamide is causing increased mutagenesis.
And this is causing the platinum signature, of course, but also we also observed
that this mafosfamide is the active compound of cyclophosphamide is
causing a very flat signature which resembles clock-like signatures.
Okay, so just to summarize this part, chemotherapy is mutagenic to
normal hematopoietic cells.
We found that platinum and thiopurines cause specific, unique signatures
in the normal stem cells of these children.
And importantly,
if children were treated with thiopurine, not all cells displayed
this SBS87.
An antiviral drug can also be mutagenic specifically
against cyclovir, and cyclophosphamide can enhance clock-like
mutagenesis, or at least cause a pattern that looks a lot like clock-like
signatures.
And so one or two things that we observed in this cohort,
which actually made us think about a second
experiment, was that we saw that indeed mutation load goes
up, but actually not all cells after treatment show an increased
mutation load. And actually, if we look closer to this
cohort of patients, we could see that--
every dot is a single cell that was sequenced of different patients, and on the
x-axis here is the latency between the end of treatment and the moment when
we got samples for diagnose two, we actually could see
that the mutation loads of these
cells seem to go back down to the baseline.
And so the dotted line here is the baseline.
So all these data have been age corrected.
And this is quite interesting, I think, because you cannot really lose mutations.
Also, a similar phenomenon was observed by Peter Campbell in
bronchial cells in people that stopped smoking.
And the other thing which is interesting is that 10 years after the end
of treatment, the risk of getting therapy-related AML also drops back to
normal levels. And so we wondered what is actually happening here.
Are some cells may be protected against mutagenesis, or
are there pathways which sensitize or
make cells resistant against chemotherapy-induced mutagenesis?
And so we were interested in trying to find out which pathways
these were.
And so to try investigate this question,
we
decided to use a new technology which combines single-cell whole genome and
transcriptome sequencing of the same cell.
And as a model system, we used children that were treated for
ALL. And the reason why we did this is because we could get bone marrow at
different time points at diagnose.
But also at week 11, there's always a bone marrow biopsy taken
after the induction therapy to see whether the child
responds to the therapy. And there's another bone marrow taken
at one year after diagnose. And so because these bone marrow
samples were taken during the treatment, we thought this would be a good
setup to test what is now different between the cells with a higher mutation
load versus a normal mutation load.
And so what we've done is we took the bone marrow of the childs that were
treated for ALL,
isolated the single cells, and then performed whole genome and transcriptome
sequencing of the same cell.
Just to show you that if you simply only look at
patients treated for ALL, we also see in those
and also at the very early time points, actually, we already see that the mutation
load goes up in these patients. So this is diagnose sample, and this is the
follow-up. So indeed, also there we already see that the mutation load goes up.
And one peculiar thing that we saw is that if we separate
the mutation load of these cells,
looking at the different differentiation states of the stem and progenitor
cells, we actually saw that the more differentiated cells were, we also see
an increased mutation load. So these are the normal hematopoietic stem cells and
the multipotent progenitors or the stem cells of the hematopoietic system.
But then if they started differentiating, we actually saw that the mutation
load went up.
They do show the same mutational signature.
So here you see the
contribution of each mutational signature to these different cell
states, basically.
And so what you see indeed is clock-like signatures, and then because these
children have been treated with thiopurines, we also see the thiopurine signature
and a little bit of signature 18 in more differentiated cells.
But what this told us is that if we really want to look for what is now the
difference between why some cells are having a higher
mutation load than another, is that we should focus on the stem cell state just to
remove the effect of the differentiation.
And so what we did is we collected cells from
five individuals
at these different time points treated for ALL, isolated only
the stem cells,
and then did the combined single-cell whole genome and transcriptome
sequencing. So we tested first a couple of cells of three individuals, but
then when this worked out, we did 100 cells of
two additional
patients, which I will show you.
And first, what we did is when we did the RNA sequencing of these cells, we did a
check whether we're actually looking at stem cells, and so we
integrated our data with an atlas, a bone marrow atlas from Zheng et al.
And here I'm just focusing on the stem and progenitor compartment, and we could
indeed see that
the cells that we assessed are actually enriched for hematopoietic stem
and multipotent progenitor cells.
So we are really looking at the earliest
cell stage in the hematopoietic system.
And so then we did the whole genome sequencing, and what you see here is the
cells of one of the individuals that we looked at with many
different cells, different time points, and this is a phylogenetic
tree of this patient. And what you actually see is that there's hardly any
relationship between each of the cells that we assessed.
And so meaning that this
blood compartment is very polyclonal in the early stages of treatment,
which kind of makes sense because they
were just treated. On the other hand, remember that
this is an ALL patient, so a lot of the
normal cells at time of diagnose were actually blasts.And so what we can do
is you can integrate this with a data set, again, by the lab of Peter
Campbell, where they made different trees across the
lifespan of the human. And then what happens if you have a clonal expansion,
which is,
for example, H-related clonal hematopoiesis, you can see that
the diversity actually in this diversity index will go down.
And so when we age, the blood becomes more clonal, and the diversity
will go down. Then actually the two samples, the two individuals for which we had
many cells, we can show that the clonality at that time is actually not
affected by the treatment.
And so the next thing we did is we tested whether we could find
differential expressed genes
in cells that have different signatures or high or low mutation
burden. And so for this, we decided to separate actually the effects of the
different chemotherapeutics that were already identified.
So again, this is the same figure that I showed you before.
So this is the pre-treatment, this is the post-treatment.
And now here this is actually the difference between post-treatment and
pre-treatment. And here you can see that there's actually two main
processes that contribute to the increased mutagenesis, and that
is the thiopurine and clock-like signatures.
And so what we can do is we can now take the cells that
have this thiopurine, because I told you already that not all cells
of this individual actually have this SBS87 in
their genome. So we can separate the ones that have and the
ones that have not, and then we can do differential expression analysis, which is
shown here.
And so one of the things that we could already see from the RNA
sequencing data is that we do not really see a difference in
cell cycle phase if we look at those two different groups.
Because one hypothesis could be that these cells have been dividing
more often, that's the reason why we see this mutagenesis by 6-MP,
but at least in these data, we don't have evidence that there is a difference in
proliferation rate between these two different groups.
If we do pathway analysis, go term analysis, we see targets that
actually make a lot of sense. So we see
apoptotic pathways, but also regulation of DNA repair and DNA damage
response. So saying that we are probably looking at something like a true
signal.
And so the other group that we focused on were these clock-like signatures.
And here what we did is we looked at the cells that have
a higher mutation burden compared to a group that have a normal
mutation burden because all cells will have clock-like signatures.
And again, that these differential expression analysis.
Also here we couldn't find a difference in cell cycle
states of the different cells.
And so I think one surprising finding for us was that if you now look at
these different genes which pop up significantly in this analysis between these two
different groups, is that there's actually only very little overlap
between the cells which have a presence or absence of
this thiopurine signature or a high or low clock-like
mutagenesis in their genome,
which I think is interesting. So it seems that there's a chemo specific
transcriptional effect.
To get some kind of validation for this experiment, what we've done is
we've taken umbilical cord blood cells again, so primary stem cells
from human cord blood, and treated them either with
6-MP or the mercaptopurine,
and then did RNA sequencing,
just to see whether we can find the same targets as in the
experiment that I showed you. And I know that it's not a perfect
validation because we're now actually not taking into account mutation load, but at
least we can get a sense whether some of the targets that we see make sense.
And what we see is that 9 to 7% of the hits can be confirmed.
So not a lot, but around 10%, which gives us a lot of confidence
that at least some of these targets are actually genuine targets.
And these are just a couple. We see different
genes involved in different processes, such as
stemness. So perhaps indeed there is a link between
differentiation and the number of mutations that you have
in a genome, as well as DNA repair and cellular processes like autophagy.
And some of these are specific to certain treatments that these cells
get.
So it seems to be that there is a specific effect of these
individual chemotherapeutics.
So to conclude this part, I showed you that ALL treatment is
mutagenic.
For ALL, specifically, the thiopurines and the cyclophosphamide seem to be very
Differentiation state is correlated with mutation burden, so the more
differentiated cells are the higher the mutation burden.
We couldn't find in the data that I showed you a difference in cell cycle state,
and so it could be that cell cycle state, so proliferation itself may not
explain differences in mutation load in these cells.
And it seems that with this experiment, we can actually start
in vivo dissection of the phenotypic causes and perhaps also
consequences of specific chemotherapeutics.
And so the goal of our research is really try to identify if we
hope to identify pathways that sensitize cells for
mutagenesis, and then perhaps we can start manipulating them.
And so what we are currently doing is we are in hematopoietic stem
cells
mutating some of the targets that we found and then exposing them to the
chemotherapy to see if the mutation burden can go down now after such
a perturbation.
And so with that, I would like to thank you for your attention.
And I specifically would like to thank Alexander Blackwell, Rini, and
Luca for the work, they actually did most of the work that I showed you
today. And thank you again for your attention.
Thank you. That was a terrific talk. I'm a little confused.
Can you explain something? You had a title on one of your slides that the
clonality is not associated with treatment, correct?
Yeah.
And do you mean the types of drugs or the
timing of the treatment? Because if it's the timing, you would
expect, depending on when you're
sampling, that when you give very aggressive chemotherapy, you
are dropping their
stem cell population as well as their other cell populations
dramatically. And, kids with ALL, their bone marrows come
roaring back. So I'm sort of surprised if the
second of the interpretation is what you're saying, is that it really doesn't
matter what state they're in.
Yeah. I think so. I was also surprised by this.
So there's different time points, right?
So there's a time point 13 weeks after treatment and one
year after treatment, and I integrated those.
And I think one thing to say is that we only selected 100
cells. So you have only a snapshot of what you
see, but still, those were randomly selected, and they hardly have any
relation to each other. So it does seem that if you purely look at the stem
cells, these are only stem cells, then it seems to be
very polyclonal at that moment still. Yeah.
So it's-
This is surprising, yeah.
So it is the bias of really looking at the stem cells that you're talking about.
Could be, yeah.
And a bias-
Yeah, because if you-- Yeah.
And not the very early differentiated cells that are coming out that when
they get
whomped by the chemotherapy, so to speak.
Exactly. These are only the cells, the hematopoietic cells, hemopoietic stem
cells, and multipotent progenitors. Yes. Yeah.
Oh, super interesting talk, and thank you very much.
And so my question is something regarding the-- similar
to the previous question. So it is really surprising
that the
mutation burden gradually decreased, and after 10 years, it returned to a
normal level, so suggesting that clearly some stem cells
survive. They're protected from the insult.
But my question is that,
nevertheless, secondary cancer have the
very high mutation burden. I believe.
I am not a pediatrician, so I'm not familiar with
tumor burden, the tumor. But then, so
first question is we can predict the
risk of developing secondary
blood cancer by seeing the mutation burden
at any time point because it is decreasing.
So what is the best predictor?
So I do have to say, so in this data where I showed that the mutation burden
decreases, those were still all patients with a therapy-related AML,
because that's the only way how we can get a bone marrow sample 10 years after
diagnosis. So these patients did have a therapy-related
AML, and the mutation burden was much higher, and it had
also
chemotherapy signatures in them. So we did know that they were all treated.
I think a better way to predict, so what we saw in
therapy-related AML, at least in children, we saw that in contrast to
adults, we saw that they were mostly driven by MLL fusions.
So fusions of the KMT2A gene, like
60% have them, in adults it's more P53 mutations.
And
they actually have a breakpoint, which is quite reproducible and in a very
short
span in the genome. So they're very close to each other.
And I think actually monitoring the breakpoint would make a lot of sense if
you want to do early detection of AML.
Okay.
And so I would actually go for the clone with deep sequencing.
But anyway, the observation is so very different from the
intuition because the secondary cancer
AML developed from so many cells that are having high
mutation, but they actually derived from very small number
population of cells-
Yeah
... that out-competed by normal stem cells. Very interesting.
Yeah. So we've generated phylogenetic trees of therapy-related AML patients, and
you can actually show that this clone was actually already
started to-- Well, the clone already arose during the treatment.
You can see that during the treatment.
And then actually in children, there was something specific.
We saw that if platinum signature is removed or the platinum treatment is removed,
then you see clonal expansion of this
therapy-related AML.
Very interesting. Thank you.
And Turkey first, I think. Yeah.
Yeah, great talk. So one question related to your multi-omic measurements.
So the DNA repair pathway came up, but from my
understanding, it's not really temporally related to the DNA damaging
insult.
Mm.
It was sometime after the exposure to thiopurines or whatever
was inducing it.
Yeah.
I'm wondering if you have thoughts about that.
Yeah. So
this is the reason why we actually went for samples that were taken
during the therapy. And it's true that this
week 13 specifically is taken one week or two weeks
after they stop induction therapy.
But I think we also need to realize that hematopoietic stem cells, they're quite
quiescent. They are thought to replicate only once every year.
Well, they probably replicate more during this treatment, but we do think that
there's still
damage at that moment still present.
So I actually think because we are so close to
the moment that these children were still receiving chemotherapy and actually still
receive chemotherapy, that we do think that there is DNA damage. Yeah.
And then, I guess related to that, would you expect,
if you looked at a little bit more mature cells, as people were saying, those might
be where your clonal expansions are happening-
Yeah
... because HSCs aren't dividing, and that's where you could see a
CH clone develop.
Yeah. This could be. This is something we need to
test. We haven't looked at it, but it might be, yeah.
Thanks.
That was a great talk. Thank you.
I'm a clinician who takes care of survivors.
In this session, I have learned a lot about the mutagenesis of the agents
we use. I am struck by how much we get away
with. Why don't we see the cancers
that occur in elderly adults in our younger patients, and
how are we getting away with so many mutagenic agents and so
many changes in the hematopoietic,
in the liver cells, et cetera, that we've seen today without
seeing more secondary cancers?
Yeah. This is a philosophical question, I would say.
And I think actually because maybe, and maybe I'm going to say
something which is provocative, but maybe
mutation accumulation, it's very necessary for the development of cancer, but
maybe it's not often rate limiting.
So what Sam was also saying that early in development
already, when the zygote starts replicating, you have around one, two
mutations per division, and a child already consists out of
1.25 trillion cells. And
we also see that if we look at birth in cells, we see already 80 mutations
in a stem cell. If you multiply those two, then you could actually do the
calculation that a healthy child, when it's born, already has more than 30,000
complete genomes mutated. And so maybe we are already filled with
mutations, and therefore, the mutagenesis maybe is not rate
limiting. Perhaps the damage that is actually being introduced
starts selecting mutated clones which are already there.
And so this may explain why we can get away with
adding so much mutagenesis. But having said that, we do see, and I
hope that we showed you during the talks, especially before, is that many
drivers that you see in these subsequent cancers are actually caused directly by
the chemotherapeutics.
Thank you.
All right. I think I'm going to conclude this session now.
I would like to thank the speakers again for their wonderful talks and thank
you for your questions and for coming to this session.